what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
Rock or I'm back
finally the rob has come back to killing
you superheroes I just got back to
Wrestlemania
where so many eyes not as good as it
used to be but it was still pretty fun
to watch it was still pretty cool to be
there and to see all that stuff happen
anyway
the last time we tried this we bit off
more than we could chew when we tried to
kill the one above all and we ended up
getting humbled and admitting defeat I
wouldn't really say we were defeated so
much as we were like temporarily set
back that's I think it's a much better
way of looking at that it was a
temporary setback in a sense that we
temporarily discovered that we can never
kill the one above us so we're not going
to let one loss stop us from continuing
in our quest to rid the world of
superheroes
after all we try to take down the god of
the Marvel Universe and there's no shame
in admitting that it can't be done
because there are still some super
powerful characters in comics that we
haven't taken out yet and you guys much
like me apparently will not be satisfied
until all the super heroes and super
villains are dead I just want to go on
record and saying we're like the best
villain team ever the robbed Corps like
we're just sitting around like plotting
like how to kill superheroes on how to
kill supervillains whoa B tie the time
that Marvel or DC makes the rock or the
villains of a comic book because no one
will defeat us the round court we are
nine hundred and fifty thousand strong
we're beastly but in today's video we're
going to regroup we're going to refocus
and turn our attention to one of the
most often overlooked but still insanely
powerful characters in the Marvel
Universe Ghost Rider
now I want to start by pointing out that
for the purposes of this video we are
focusing only on those individuals who
have been designated ghost riders
because they possess a spirit of
vengeance which is a spirit given to
them by a divine force from which they
derive their powers what this means is
that our discussion will apply to
individuals such as Johnny Blaze and
Danny ketch but will not apply to
Marvel's newest Ghost Rider Robby Reyes
since Robby gets his powers from the
spirit of a deceased human and is
therefore not a true Ghost Rider the
reason for making this distinction is
that given the limited number of
appearances that Robby's made in the
comics we simply don't have enough
information on what the extent of his
powers actually are and so figuring out
I think what it would take to kill him
is a task that we'll have to reserve for
a later time when his characters a bit
more fleshed out in the comics and when
Marvel stops being stupid and rolls them
back over into agents of shield now with
that in mind let's look at why Ghost
Rider is so hard to kill now when you
typically think of the most powerful
characters in the Marvel Universe Ghost
Rider is usually not a name that comes
up most people think of like Galactus or
Thanos or Silver Surfer the robbed core
or some other cosmic entity that's out
there but as we're getting ready to see
Ghost Rider is just as formidable as
most other characters typically placed
and the strongest here of the Marvel
Universe now I'm not going to go into a
full discussion on Ghost Rider powers
here because we release a video on that
previously that you can go back and
check out we did a vs. series with Ghost
Rider vs. spawn but what I do want to
focus on here is that for all intents
and purposes the power Ghost Rider
derives from the spirit of vengeance
makes him effectively immortal one
reason for this is that Ghost Rider has
virtually limitless durability to the
extent that he cannot be harmed by
conventional physical means what this
means is that the Ghost Rider could go
toe-to-toe with even the strongest
characters in the Marvel Universe like
the thing juggernaut or even the Hulk
and lived to tell the tale
in fact Ghost Rider did battle the Hulk
in a strongest form the world breaker -
basically what amounted to a standstill
during the world war hulk event so in
terms of physical damage
we're simply never going to be able to
deal enough damage to Ghost Rider to
kill him so we have to move on to more
mystic methods to that end there is some
precedent in Marvel Comics for Ghost
Rider dying for instance in the siege of
darkness event the ghost riders killed
by the demon zarathos who absorbs ghost
riders essence what this tells us is
that although Ghost Rider can't
physically be harmed he is vulnerable to
divine demonic and mystical attacks this
is further reinforced by another
encounter Johnny Blaze has with a
supernatural entity known as the demo
Gorge who is his s the vampire blade
during the midnight massacre crossover
now blade with his powers greatly
augmented absorbed Johnny blazes powers
and subsequently killed him now this
gives us a basic blueprint for killing
Ghost Rider find a way to separate the
supernatural force of the Ghost Rider
from its human host this of course is a
difficult proposition for any being that
does not possess sufficient divine power
but there might be a work around here
and I say might be because the evidence
for this actually exists outside of the
mainline Marvel Universe and the
alternate reality series what if issue
number 28 which asked the question what
would happen if Johnny Blaze was
separated from Ghost Rider now in the
story Johnny Blaze and the Ghost Rider
are separated by a mage known as as
Ozzie Hornsby who then possesses the
body of the Ghost Rider itself later
blades kills horns meet with a mystical
artifact called the scimitar of ramen
Beth which not only kills hornsby but
also The Ghost Rider and Johnny Blaze
himself along with him now what we might
not be able to put too much stock into
this since it happens to be an alternate
reality it does give us an idea the
perhaps artifacts imbued with mystical
energy can be effective in separating
Ghost Rider from its host now ever side
note here if a version of the scimitar
does exist in the main Marvel Universe
then separating the ghost rider from its
host may not even be necessary as it
seems the weapon can kill the ghost
rider outright although it is unclear
whether there is an analogue for the
scimitar we do know of another artifact
that does exist that may have the
potential to kill Ghost Rider in a sword
called justicar now justicar was forged
by a former agent of 0's named foundry
who was subsequently used to kill other
agents with zarathos well we can't say
definitively if it would work on Ghost
Rider
there is at least a chance that it would
considering the 0th oz is the demon that
originally gave Johnny Blaze that Ghost
Rider powers and if the sword can kill
agents it may be able to kill the ghost
rider as well there is also evidence
that ghost riders can be killed by
angelic forces as we've seen in Jason
Owens run on the title in which an angel
named Zadkiel used Danny ketch as an
instrument to steal the power of the
ghost riders all over the world which
resulted in the death of the host in
most cases while most people are unable
to summon the power of angels it's not
unfeasible to harness divine power
unless your doses and use it against a
singular ghost rider in fact we saw this
happen under the writing of Garth Ennis
and Ghost Rider vol 5 issue number 5
when Johnny Blaze is shot in the head
with a bullet that's been dipped in holy
water and sent to hell now what did this
technically count as killing him is open
to interpretation but since it
effectively removes him from earth and
tracks him in hell for eternity I'm
pretty much going to count it in so
having said that it is incredibly hard
to kill Ghost Rider I mean it really
really is difficult he's a spirit of
engine he literally exists to fight the
immortal
and then send them back to hell it's a
very very difficult situation so in
conclusion while it is incredibly hard
to kill Ghost Rider it seems there are
three basic ways to do it first you can
separate it from toast and then kill the
host is important to note that this only
killed the host not the spirit but the
spirit but most likely be banished to
helmets again so we've pretty much
accomplished our goal
the second is to find an artifact that's
capable of destroying the spirit or the
third it's using a weapon containing
some form of holy energy and send the
Ghost Rider back to hell but regardless
of which one it is that you pick the
Ghost Rider pretty much ends up being
defeated ends up being killed so I think
we serve our purpose here members of the
Rob core with that being said next week
I don't believe we've done this yet but
next week we are going to kill grant
guess what I love you man I really
really love Grant Gustin I think is
amazing flash but we're going to kill
the flash so that sounds ominous
doesn't a promise no harm will befall
Grant Gustin however we are going to see
if we can kill Barry Allen the flash in
DC Comics after that maybe we'll move on
to Wally West but if you guys are new
here to comment explain make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
catch you guys later peace
[Music]